the world is counting down to the new
year but not everyone is ready to leave
the past behind
I'm from the future
[Music]
I came here in a time machine that you
invented now I need your help to get
back to the year 1985.
that's right it's almost 2023 but people
are nostalgic for the past and we all
wanted to be what the 80s the 90s just
look at our closets flare jeans fanny
packs tie-dye and we cannot forget about
the mullet check out monitoring the
business in the front party in the back
days I'm telling you that kid right
there like two weeks ago he knew a thing
yeah
Kennedy uh should you break out the crop
top again let's check this out that's
almost too hot for five o'clock that's
Chanel by the way
and Tom your sweater vest and pleated
jeans uh that's a hot commodity I like
that look at the hair I wish you could
see the pants because they were
high-waisted and the belt was a little
lower you know what I'm talking about
yeah
that's an advertisement it was our Harry
Style and Katie I think this was from
last week is that a neon fanny pack
you're wearing yeah look at those pants
and look at my glasses neon glasses to
match the fanny pack super stylish and
Richard I know you're the fashion guy is
this a tie-dye and purple pant combo yes
what was I thinking do we call that
Vogue is that what that is yeah yeah
but you're ahead of the curve and you're
constantly rocking the Retro look look
at this there you go I brought it back
to the 2000s
that's pretty good is that also Chanel
that is not Chanel I don't know anything
about Chanel
um
so what do you guys think about this uh
we're all nostalgic for the 80s and 90s
we talk about movies like Top Gun had
the top movie Kennedy what do you think
should we uh why are we rocking it back
to the 80s and 90s I love the 90s I'm
I'm a fan I would love for us to go back
there and you know different genres of
music different musicians were getting
together making really interesting music
people weren't grousing about cultural
appropriation uh artists were excited
that people were inspired by what they
were putting out and you know I love
baby doll dresses and docs I've never
I've never gotten away from it and I
will not be shamed into into the now I
love it I love that look my only problem
with responding to this I don't know
what a baby doll dresser or a doc is Doc
Martens okay Doc Martin I do understand
I got complimented on my suit by Richard
yesterday and I like had a little award
I printed out
do you know how bad I dress uh Richard
what do you think about this I mean I
thought Kennedy might talk about music
music we've got movies that are throwing
it back fashion obviously is something
you know about that we're throwing it
back to yeah I think retro for whatever
the reason Retro's in and I was sort of
thinking about it before while prepping
for the show and I think about like what
was I watching on television this year
and I was watching a Sex in the City
reboot which is what it and and now and
what is it just like and just like that
over the past couple weeks I was
watching the best man Final Chapter
another reboot of a show that came out
when I was in Middle School right or a
movie that came out when I was in Middle
School now they have a series so the
clearly reboots and retro was in in the
2020s you know Katie they say everything
kind of comes back around there are
certain things that we want to leave in
the past but I read the other day
um I I think it was still alone was
saying I can't remember now saying that
the movies in the 80s were kind of
looked bad on and now everybody's like
you know what those were actually some
pretty awesome movies well I don't know
if it's so much retro or just recycled
like going back around right the movies
were good and if you look at the way
Hollywood Hollywood is today everything
as Kennedy was alluding to is so
tiptoeing around offending people that
it's the same cookie cutter movie plot
every single time and it's very boring
and the creativity actually has gone
completely out the window so it's very
predictable and nobody wants to go see
those movies but back to the fashion I
always find it very funny when normal
attire for certain groups of people
becomes fashionable and you'll
understand this so like plaid flannel
shirts I wear plaid flannel shirts all
the time overalls people wear those to
go to work in lots of different parts of
the country tie-dye I mean don't be
digging the hippies right or you know
there are lots of hippies who like to
wear tie-dye every single day maybe my
mother being one of them and bandana
headbands that's something that people
use all the time so you know I like that
my normal fashion is considered Chic and
in style
anything new you're just going to keep
recycling those in your I mean I'll buy
new things
people were ahead of the curve including
people who wear plaid that is such a
good point every generation feels like
they invented Neon right and it's like
it's just no yeah but the fanny pack is
an amazing tool especially very
practical and people think it's cool now
to put it as a crossbody rather than on
the fanny I think that's cooler so
that's a cool way to wear it but it's
still a fanny pack my wheelchair has a
fanny pack for when I go to like Disney
and stuff like I got a little fanny pack
on my wheelchair Tom I know you're a
fashion guy I'm not going to ask you
about clothes or movies what I'm gonna
ask you about is even our appliances
even like Electronics like people are
giving up their smart headphones and
they want like the Walkman headphones
everybody wants retro yes and it's it's
not just because they just have General
Nostalgia they're looking at
entertainment almost every show every
good
TV series movie it's said in the past
because you're not allowed to tell
stories anymore in an honest way because
everyone's policing their speech so if
you want to set an interesting story you
put it in the past people can say
Politically Incorrect things yeah they
can have romances they can do things
without all of the speech codes it's
also kind of annoying because everyone's
looking at their phone so it's terrible
when your characters are all like
staring at their phone and things like
that people have to you know the other
day I was watching an old movie with my
daughters and the guy had to put pull
over I got to find a phone you know they
had to actually go find a pay phone and
put a coin in it but I'm listening to
Hi-Fi do you guys have a picture of my
Hi-Fi at home look at my Sony this is my
dad's stereo uh turntable look at that
thing oh nice it's so nice to put a
record on you have to put it on you have
to listen then you have to get up take
the needle off put it back
actually on that Hi-Fi is that is that
an original or is that a newly made to
look that way no it's actually the one I
grew up with uh I bought it in 1968 and
that was the stereo that was in our
living room and I recently he took you
know knocked the dust off it and I had
it restored and now I play records on
and it works I I didn't I had it
restored in the you know I had them
clean out the dirt but I didn't have to
fix it the turntable still works plays
records at 33 and a third it's
interesting because 50 of all physical
music sold is now LPS it's now vinyl and
it was for a long time that the people
were you know Switching gears and and
going from tapes to CDs and and now
they're they're buying Hard music again
because the sound is different and for a
lot of people it's better but now the
vinyl Market has absolutely exploded so
for people our daughter's age they go to
record stores again and and they try and
but it's it's I never try and tell them
what I like I want them to discover it
on their own and my daughter came back
with uh Dr Dre The Chronic speaking
speaking of your daughter my son's here
he's 13. so gen Z they might dress like
us but they don't really really acts
like this and I certainly don't party
like we do so according to this study
people born between the mid 90s and the
mid 2000s are behaving way better than
their parents generation I don't I don't
know about behaving better but maybe not
getting in as much trouble 57 percent of
today's kids admit attending a rager
with their friends a rager I don't know
I don't think I ever went to a ranger we
had keg parties anyway with our friends
once a month down from 80 percent in the
90s I mean this is a problem we really
need to focus on here the biggest Factor
eliminating fun isn't even stricter
parents it's technology so you know it's
basically they're just on their phone
all the time yes and you can find your
kids so if you have Snapchat and your
kids have Snapchat you just go to the
snap map and you find out exactly where
there's so many ways to track a child
but you know you know like we would get
in the car and be like bye I'll be back
at 11 30 at curfew and just like like
you know climbing water towers and doing
Richard I don't know nothing about Big
Town small town I mean did you go to
Raiders
is but I will say
um I think your Kennedy's right like I
think when my mom dropped me off at
college and I was like all right bye I
went to college at a time where Facebook
you had to have a at something
something.edu which means my mom
couldn't get on there so and also there
wasn't photo albums on Facebook then
there wasn't a all you have was like a
like one picture on your Facebook so
like you basically had College Years
that were undiscoverable it was a great
thing now kids are like I don't know
what they do on college campuses anymore
it wasn't as fun as when we were there
so you're the last generation that can
actually go into politics is what you're
saying yes pretty much people ask me
about your Facebook run for office like
well when they destroy the internet
I think that I like to think that they
are terrified of this kind of behavior
being documented so I know a lot of
folks who say what happened in the 70s
and the 80s stays in the 70s and the 80s
it wasn't documented so therefore if you
were having parties or having fun as a
normal young person it would destroy the
rest of your life because it was all
going to be streamed on Tic Tac or on
Instagram so I'd like to to think that
they're being more responsible but I do
think that it's that they can talk to
their friends on the phone they don't
have to go to a party to see their
friends Tom this is the same generation
that ushered in the eating of Tide Pods
I don't know if it's more responsible
yeah I think I was ahead of my time I
was not doing drugs and not having sex
way back in the 80s
resume well maybe 23 will bring us
fashion from the old days and uh record
players that are absolutely in pristine
condition and for me it's the 1970s and
80s pickup trucks that are costing way
too much money now because people are
discovering how awesome they are yeah
all right the end of the year fun
doesn't stop there but uh be sure to
tune in to the five's New Year special
this Saturday at 7 00 p.m eastern time
and count down to the All-American New
Year live from Nashville starting at 10
p.m Eastern hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else